i live my dream gary i don't have time i  have mortgages and bills and  responsibilities in my job i don't have  time for my side hustle my twitch  channel my instagram account my shopify  store  selling hoodies and i keep getting to  this new place which is  talk to me about your bills why'd you  buy  an apartment that stretches you why is  your car so fancy why do you need the  new gucci  every time why are you going out  thursday friday and saturday night like  why are you going to coachella why are  you going to  avengers opening night and buying the  biggest piece of popcorn and candy like  the answer to all of your questions  is not how much money you make or how  much time you have it's what you're  spending your money  on this is dreams we're talking about  we're talking about dreams